[Musique]
ma mère et mon père se sont rencontrés à
châteauroux dans la cantine qu'elle
fréquentait il ya trois ans d'amour
l'amour conjugal c'est celui que tout le
monde veut suite et à la passion et
ensuite
ce que j'appelle la rencontre et des
vitamines histoire c'est l'histoire il
était rentré dans sa vie elle ne voyait
pas en sortir
ces marchés
c'est pas avec toi moi non
je pouvoir faire ce que je veux c'est
l'histoire d'un amour éternel débat nous
appuyons centrale solaire qui ceinturent
de rien c'est très bien je serai pas
toujours dire évidemment si tu avais été
riche toit était différent salle où l'on
se dit à tous
j'aimerais bien lui reconnaît chantal je
mens pas d'argent ça n'intéresse pas
votre fils philippe et moi avons un bébé
de six mois que je sais je voudrais
pouvoir lui donner des nouvelles de sa
fille à vapeur ça te fasse mal de le
revoir vivant puisque pour chantal
landry qui la reconnaissent j'suis pas
reconnaître son talent je me suis marié
grandir la ville
je lève ma fille seule depuis qu'il est
petit
quand tu es petit elle connaissait
quasiment pas son père il a repris
contact avec m ça fait longtemps qu'on
active et qu'il apporte beaucoup de
choses dans ma vie t'aime je te rends
compte si j'avais vécu avec lui tout ce
que j'aurais appris on n'est pas une
femme deux personnes dans une maison de
famille où tu sais ce que c'est si une
question tellement contraignant c'est
l'histoire
[Musique]
non